[Music]
you have daughters who are older mm-hm
and sometimes I'd like to ask people
what's it I mean later on when they
start to get to dating age right I
already cannot even imagine that
happening or how I would feel about that
how do you handle that well I think you
always you got to answer the door when
they come to the door right so when that
when the guy comes to the door and rings
the doorbell you have to make sure
you're the one that answers yeah yeah
answer the door yeah you know so they
look they usually they're looking up at
you at that age or at least somewhat in
the same level unless they're play
basketball for the high school team
right right and but my daughter I'm not
gonna let her date so she's in her late
30s that's gonna be my rule well you
still got to answer the door yeah yeah
so they answer the door and you look
them right in the eye look I'm right in
the eye and you say can I help you look
at those eyes though you've got those
great you've got those great serious
eyes I don't think look at that you yeah
you're good I don't intimidate my eyes
are just like if I say can I help you
don't say good night it's not the same
hand off your daughter yeah it's not the
same you've got you've got those you've
you know you've killed people in movies
you've killed people in you know my
daughter's have you know complain that I
in Tim you know that my dear friends
means they say you know dad my friends
are scared of you that's good what have
you done anything to scare no just just
from the movies and stuff like that Yeah
right that's good you have that going
for you no you want what at one time I
was a there was a ha you know in this
area where we live this Halloween it's a
big things if thousands of people come
by and I was walking my youngest
daughter one time and I had a flashlight
was very dark out and when I got home
all my daughter my oldest daughters
friends were watching a fight there was
a big price fight that night right and
they were all in the screening room that
I have and I went in there and they said
my wife worries let me go although all
the kids are in the screening room so I
opened the screening room door and it
was pitch dark in there but I had my
flashlight so I turned on the flashlight
and I went like one by one I kind of
looked at him
you could almost you know hear him go
yeah they're like raccoons going through
the trash impassable what's crazy is
that's a great technique to have the
flashlight that's what the police do you
know they they flash like when you open
the door just flash the light into the
face you know like turn around yeah
exactly
we're an Andy Garcia mask so they'll be
intimidated